[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal
sur tv 78 l'essentiel de l'information
locale en ce lundi 23 septembre voici
les principaux titres
l'examen du projet de loi sur l'économie
circulaire en examen au sénat dès demain
la sénatrice les républicains en des
yvelines martha de sidrac en est le
rapporteur elle est l'invitée de cette
édition et nous dira pourquoi elle se
montre critique envers ce texte dont
l'enjeu est de limiter à le gaspillage à
le premier ministre présent lors des
journées parlementaires du groupe modem
à l'assemblée l'événement se déroulait
dans les yvelines en fin de semaine
dernière principal enjeu resserrer les
liens avec la république en marche
et puis le bilan des journées du
patrimoine nous irons à elancourt
versailles mais aussi en vallée de
chevreuse pour revivre les principaux
rendez vous du week end
tout d'abord une photo elle s'appelle
janice âgée de 30 ans elle a été
poignardée à mort par son mari lors
d'une dispute survenue à
maisons-laffitte sa fille de 18 mois a
été placé dans une structure de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance quand à l'auteur des
faits il est incarcéré à fresnes depuis
hier elle s'il est passé aux aveux il
n'a en revanche donné aucune explication
aux enquêteurs
le décès de janis porte à quatre le
nombre de féminicide dans les yvelines
depuis le début de l'année est justement
le collectif nous tout nous toute
annonce de réunion dans le département
le 27 septembre à poissy le 10 octobre à
trappes afin de préparer à la grande
marche contre les violences faites aux
femmes
à paris le 23 novembre prochain
[Musique]
réparez recyclé surtout ne plus jeter
l'économie circulaire objet de toutes
les attentions avec un projet de loi qui
sera examiné en séance plénière au sénat
à partir de demain mardi 24 septembre
martin décidera gabon soir on sait que
la venue en plateau sénatrice les
républicains à des yvelines vous êtes le
rapporteur de ce texte et je vais
débuter par quelques mots de la
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie brune
poirson
il nous appartient d'inventer de
nouveaux modes de consommation
d'alimentation de production afin de
lutter contre les lobbys qui souhaitent
continuer à nous tirer en arrière pour
que nous restions au 20e siècle est ce
que le texte présenté au sénat est aussi
ambitieux qui le semble alors écoutez on
partage les objectifs de madame la
secrétaire d'état
mais je crois que nous n'y sommes pas
avec le texte qui nous a été présentée
en examen beaucoup de déceptions de ma
part à de la part de mes collègues de la
commission aménagement du territoire et
développement durable
on espérait véritablement un nouveau
souffle pour l'environnement pour nos
territoires pour nos concitoyens on a
entendu tous les appels qui que nous
avons tous partagé mais hélas vraiment
je le dis parce que je le pense
les objectifs nous les partageons en
revanche je pense que les moyens qui
sont proposés à travers ce texte initial
n'y sont pas on va rentrer un peu plus
en détail sur ce texte le sénat qui émet
des réserves lors des premières lectures
qui ont déjà eu lieu sur la question de
la consigne notamment qu'on finit le
plastique
vous êtes content pour voir la consigne
non la consigne est quelque chose est un
dispositif qui peut être très
intéressant mais encore faut-il employés
à bon escient
donc lorsque l'on interroge nos
concitoyens on voit bien que dans
l'opinion publique la consigne qui est
plébiscitée c'est celle du réemploi et
c'est celle que j'ai introduit au niveau
du texte justement puisque consignes
pour le réemploi oui consignes pour
recyclage non et là je pense que je vous
dois quelques explications
tout simplement parce que aujourd'hui en
réalité le sujet la question qui se pose
à nous c'est la collecte des plastiques
dans leur ensemble on le sait bien
l'opinion publique est très sensible à
cela et nous aussi
et je pense que c'est cette collecte la
des plastiques dans leur ensemble
qui doit être amélioré et c'est le sens
des propositions que je fais dans le
cadre de ce texte
ce qu'il manque à ce texte aussi
peut-être selon vous c'est la réduction
à la source de la production aussi des
déchets la lutte contre le suremballage
par exemple la pollution au plastique
encore la lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire tout ça n'apparaît pas dans
le texte
tout cela n'apparaissait pas dans le
texte initial donc nous l'avons amender
avec mes collègues de la commission
nous allons débattre dès demain en
séance publique et nous allons et nous
l'espérons en tout cas trouver un
consensus je ne suis pas du tout
désespéré je suis très sereine parce que
je pense que l'objectif est là nous le
partageons tous collectivement et
j'espère que le gouvernement nous suivra
puisque nous allons un peu plus loin en
matière environnementale avec notre
texte aujourd'hui bouclée ça veut dire
qu'il faut des sanctions par exemple sur
les fabricants parle de suremballage oui
en réalité nous proposons un une
trajectoire quinquennal en fait à
l'ensemble des producteurs de plastique
de manière à ce que nous puissions avoir
des des moments de revoyure et qu'on
puisse contrôler véritablement cette
production
et puis surtout ce qui nous importe
énormément c'est que au niveau de la
collecte qui aujourd'hui se fait très
bien dans nos bacs les français
aujourd'hui ont complètement assimilé le
geste de tri chez eux
en revanche il ya un geste qu'il
faudrait que nous améliorons c'est le
sens de la proposition c'est celui qui
est hors foyer vous voyez la petite
bouteille plastique nomades que nous
avons tous dans nos sacs à main la
petite barque est de la salade qu'on a
acheté chez le boulanger et une fois
utilisé on la jette dans la poubelle
quand on est si vite mais parfois elle
finit dans le caniveau donc c'est un
petit peu dommage
donc l'idée véritablement c'est que l'on
puisse collecter l'ensemble de tous ces
plastiques et que l'on puisse en même
temps à la fois avoir un geste
écocitoyen éco gestes qui ne soit pas
monétariser puisque dans la consigne il
y a quand même ce message qui moi me
déplaît un tout petit peu je ne vous le
cache pas c'est de dire en réalité le
plastique l'air celui de votre bouteille
à une valeur donc celui ci on va faire
très attention de bien le collecter pour
pouvoir bien le récupérer et le reste
des emballages en plastique au fond rien
n'est fait pour voilà
il avait évoqué brièvement mais ces
déchets sauvages finalement que l'on
peut jeter
si on ne fait pas preuve d'esprit
civique que c'est même un échelon
supplémentaire quelquefois lorsqu'on
voit des entreprises des particuliers
qui se débarrassent de leurs déchets est
une plaie pour les élus locaux et ça
peut se terminer quelques fois en drame
ont gardé en mémoire le décès du maire
de signer cet été qui s'est opposé
justement à des déchets sauvages et puis
l'administré elle a renversé en camion
il est décédé
le maire de signes j'imagine que vous
aviez ça à l'esprit aussi lorsque vous
avez examiner le texte de protéger aussi
les élus et de pouvoir agir contre les
décharges sauvages et toutes ces actions
parfaitement vous l'avez parfaitement
décrit nous avons ce souci justement de
tous ces déchets sauvages qui pour
beaucoup aussi dans lesquels on retrouve
cette petite bouteille plastique
quand je dis bouteilles plastique parce
qu'effectivement la consigne d'une telle
qu'elle est décrite par le gouvernement
ils focalisaient le sud mais tout ce qui
est plastique en fait d' usage est aussi
souvent des déchets issus de la filière
bâtiment
vous savez qu'il ya un grand volet aussi
dans ce texte autour de la filière du
bâtiment responsabilité élargie du
producteur ou pas donc nous dans notre
proposition c'est de dire on n'impose
rien un vrai pardon responsabilité
élargie du producteur ou système
équivalent on laisse la filière
s'organise et ce que l'on veut nous en
revanche ce que l'on a imposé dans le
texte que je propose c'est ce sont en
réalité des résultats
donc nous souhaitons des résultats que
nos que l'on espère obtenir à travers en
fait une exigence de maillage une
exigence aussi d'amplitude horaire le
secteur du bâtiment n'a pas forcément la
même amplitude horaire qu'un secteur
tertiaire
nous souhaitons également aussi qu'il y
ait une traçabilité de tous les
matériaux du bâtiment
et puis évidemment vous savez vous
l'avez sans doute beaucoup entendu
également dans différentes propositions
qui puisse y avoir un certificat pour
que tout maître d'ouvragé sache
lorsqu'il fait commande d'un de travaux
où vont les déchets de son bâtiment
ça nous semble indispensable donc ça
nous l'avons mis en dur dans le texte
nous l'avons sorti de ce qui devait
passer par habilitations et ordonnances
parce qu'on estime que ce sont des
sujets pour lesquels
au détour d'une rame de signes qui est
quelque chose que nos élus locaux vivent
au quotidien sur les territoires ce
texte concernant l'économie circulaire
est très vaste et vous allez l'amendé au
maximum on l'a bien compris lors des
prochaines séances au sénat des
entreprises dans les yvelines en tout
cas se sont déjà engagés dans cette
économie circulaire c'est le cas dans
les yvelines
je vous le disais avec cette nouvelle
société attitude filiale du groupe la
poste installé à buc son activité la
collecte auprès des entreprises le tri
est l'envoi du papier pour son recyclage
marlène iapichino dolf blondel
[Musique]
on voit très bien ici vous avez le coeur
de l'activité nouvelle attitude
donc on va recevoir ici toute la
collecte des facteurs qui vont nous
emmener tout ce qui est papier de bureau
nous recevrait du papier de la poste
c'est ça vous triez ces saloperies il
repart ou chez des papiers pour de
recyclage
lesquels n'ont arrivée vous déchargez
ici voilà les camions amis vous ont des
charges tous les chariots et ensuite on
va les emmener à la pesée
ici c'est le poste de pesée on à la
balance qui se trouve là on met les
chariots dessus et ensuite on va rentrer
la provenance du papier on l'est pèse on
les emmène au plateau de tri alors maxi
nous vous battrons tous les six mois
alors le rôle actuellement classé de
recevoir un agrément l'écrit couleurs on
sait par le blanc 2 par exemple des
enveloppes kraft comme ceux ci on a des
bacs de récupération pour sable pour le
carton également et tout ce qu'on
appelle gros mc en fait c'est tout ce
qui est libre
mélange de 42 2 tours en gros le sac
papier de voilà est également le
plastique on recycle de l'autre côté
puis partir en chêne ensuite dans notre
cible est donc maintenant ce qu'on a
travaillé a été compressé et se retrouve
dans des bals que vous voyez à côté de
moi et ça valait direct c'est le passé
[Musique]
il ya encore une marge de progression
importante auprès des entreprises
justement pour favoriser le secteur
oui bien sûr dans tous les secteurs dans
toutes les filières puisque le recyclage
évidemment est quelque chose de
fondamental l important dans l'économie
circulaire quelle que soit la matière
première
merci ma retraite y est peut-être passé
sur ce plateau à la veille de l'examen
donc au sénat de ce texte sur l'économie
circulaire juste peut-être un petit clin
d'oeil pour nous expliquer le ruban que
vous avez merci de me poser la question
il s'agit en fait du ruban d'or dans le
cadre de septembre d'or qui est en
actions que l'on mène pour recueillir
des dons pour l'institut gustave roussy
pour innover et favoriser la recherche
du cancer pédiatrique donc contre le
cancer pédiatrique merci de m'avoir posé
la question vrai lui demain vous aurez
ce petit ruban lors de l'ouverture de la
session absolument pas ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir suivre là qui vont sur la
cession pour voir la discussion vous
comprendrez la cnci absolument merci
beaucoup encore à vous mais là c'est sur
ce plateau nous évoquions la l'économie
circulaire le recyclage et bien sachez
que l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines propose justement à ses
habitants des kits de compostage
assortis d'un suivi personnalisé d'ici
2021 à la communauté d'agglomération
entend en effet réduire le volume des
déchets est de 1700 tonnes le 28
septembre samedi lui aura donc des
distribution de composteurs individuels
pour des formations aussi au centre
technique basée sur trappe nous y
reviendrons la politique est à nouveau
avec le déplacement du premier ministre
dans les yvelines edouard philippe était
à toussus-le-noble en fin de semaine
dernière pour les journées
parlementaires du groupe modem une
visite placée notamment sous le signe de
la transition écologique aurélie ronze
margot du roi étaient sur place
elle c'est ici à l'aérodrome de toussus
le noble que se trouve l'avion alpha
électro ce biplace à motorisation
électrique est présenté aujourd'hui dans
le cadre des journées parlementaires du
groupe modem
le premier ministre edouard philippe est
également présent le président de mon
groupe patrick mignola m'a demandé de
réfléchir à valoriser deux initiatives
l'une sur la tranquillité publique et
l'autre sur la manière dont on peut sur
les territoires faire évoluer la
transition écologique depuis quelques
mois l'aérodrome de toussus a mis en
place une expérimentation de réduction
des nuisances sonores
parallèlement il accueille l'alpha
électro avion entièrement électrique
dotée d'une autonomie de 140 km et qui
ne génère aucune émission de co2 c'est
une cire construction formidable attrait
très intéressante du point de vue de
l'aéronautique au d'état
toussus-le-noble du poids de vue deux
des ingénieurs du point de vue de la
recherche du point de vue des grandes
écoles et comme vous savez j'ai été
ministre de l'éducation de la recherche
donc pour moi c'est très important pour
les 46 députés présents ces journées
sont l'occasion de se pencher sur les
sujets de l'automne il est également de
tradition que le premier ministre vienne
rencontrer les parlementaires de la
majorité
c'est bien qu'ils soient fidèles à ce
rendez vous et ça montre aussi l'intérêt
d'avoir un pluralisme au sein de la
majorité le groupe de la république en
marche le groupe modem qui se qui se
complète d'une certaine façon avec
chacun leur histoire
un déjeuner a clôturé ces deux journées
de travaux déjeuner durant lequel le
premier ministre edouard philippe a
souligné la bonne entente qui régnait au
sein du groupe parlementaire modem nous
ouvrons à présent une large page
consacrée aux journées du patrimoine
douze millions de personnes y auraient
participé en france selon le ministère
de la culture dans les yvelines des
centaines de sites étaient ouverts
notamment la commanderie à elancourt qui
pour l'occasion proposer une api manif
casque sur les oreilles les visiteurs
sont devenus les héros de scènes de
cinéma maligne à pishin oman en radeau
partons pour une visite de la
commanderie d'elancourt un peu
différente
vous jouez le rôle de jean pierre bacri
qui s'appelle nicolas dans le film
muni d'un casque audio les visiteurs
doivent suivre la bande sonore pour
devenir les héros de scènes de cinéma
une déambulation chorégraphique inédite
appelée api manif 1/2 tourner dans ces
raconté me mets dans la commanderie qui
parle de l'histoire de la commanderie
mais qui fait le lien aussi aux projets
culturels de la commanderie api manif
mission fantaisie est une création de
david rolland un chorégraphe basé à
nantes
une commande qui l'a créée spécialement
pour la commanderie si vous n'avez pas
traîner en chemin nous semble maintenant
sur la pelouse devant le restaurant au
mime danse chant une déambulation
ludique et très joyeuse
choquant
ah ah
courtois
pas
enfin
les participants ont tout donné pendant
une heure lors de cet habit manif moi
j'adore me déplacer comme ça en dansant
le rythme me convient c'est original
on va dire après par rapport à ma
personnalité je sais pas si ça
correspond exactement mais il y avait
d'énergie dans le groupe donc on se
prend quand même au jeu j'ai proposé que
ce soit faux boulot tous les matins
pendant 10 minutes
tout simplement cet apu manif organisée
samedi à 15h à la commanderie
d'elancourt a rassemblé une vingtaine de
personnes
autres lieux ouverts pendant ces
journées du patrimoine l'hôtel
particulier autre ambiance de madame du
barry maîtresse du roi louis 15
aujourd'hui chambre de commerce le site
conserve ses décors et ses oeuvres
remarquables regarder elle n'en a été
propriétaire que trois ans mais a laissé
son nom
madame du barry la dernière favorite du
roi louis 15 pour ces journées du
patrimoine ne siège de la cci versailles
yvelines dévoile ses secrets historiques
et curiosités comme c'est mon genre de
spaghetti avec les doigts les curiosités
du grand tour c'était que les gens
allaient à naples il était capable c'est
assez surpris de voir ces gens manger
des pâtes dans la ruche et donc c'est ce
que l'on peut voir ce personnage de la
commedia dell arte qui mange ses
maccarone et comme on disait à l'époque
avec les doigts devenu bâtiments
militaires sous la révolution le site et
le siège de la chambre de commerce
depuis 1937 sous le regard des visiteurs
tableau il poserait d'époque on connaît
mal ce bâtiment mais qu effectivement on
est un peu attiré par la façade puis
l'histoire que qui se cache derrière ces
murs c'est surtout l'architecturé de ces
salles qui sont pratiquement d'origine
je dire au niveau
les planches du tracé et puis des
boiseries qui sont superbes
c'est d'abord le jardin qui a excité ma
curiosité parce que habitant la maison
d'à côté et j'ai une vue plongeante sur
le grand jardin
le bâtiment je connaissais déjà un petit
peu la maison parce que j'ai assisté à
des conférences qui s'y tiennent
régulièrement
l'hôtel a connu une histoire mouvementée
une petite histoire au coeur de la
grande mise en parallèle pour l'occasion
avec la nouvelle bd de cherrie laudrin
présents ce jour là pour une dédicace ou
versailles a bien sûr une grande place
et pour terminer ce tour d'horizon des
manifestations proposées pendant les
journées du patrimoine direction la
vallée de chevreuse domaine de saint
paul château de dampierre ou encore des
mesnuls accueillait les visiteurs
mathilde 2000 sur des images de
gwenaëlle sentiment c'est un retour dans
le passé pour le château des mesnuls qui
propose une reconstitution lors du règne
de louis 15 costumes décoration ateliers
jeux de rôles étaient prévues toute la
journée pour accueillir les visiteurs
animations axées cette année
principalement sur les costumes les
costumes multi-époques donc du 15e
siècle jusqu'au xviiie un peu de lempire
aussi le château des mesnuls est réservé
à l'année par des entreprises comme le
domaine de saint paul qui depuis 2012
est un centre pour séminaires en 1959 le
domaine était alors un centre de
recherche pour des ingénieurs et de
l'expertisé du bâtiment on a mis en
visite pas les deux les trois bâtiments
emblématiques qui sont donc soldées
c'est qu'ils étaient sains au décès ce
bâtiment à 3 kit qui a été entièrement
transformée en salle de séminaire on a
aussi un autre bâtiment qui était paré
un vol d'essai et bien sûr l'hôtel
restaurant
direction le village du tremblay sur
mauldre qui a privilégié pour ce
week-end une déambulation sur les pas du
poète blaise cendrars une façon de
visiter le village mais aussi de
parfaire ses connaissances littéraires
dans la partie du cimetière où ses
cendres ont été transférés en 1994
on est remonté jusque là mairie pour
lire son article consacré au village
pendant la guerre en 939
et pour terminer devant sa maison qui
est un lieu privé nous avons lu quelques
textes qui évoquent la maison
l'intérieur et l'extérieur
un week end riche en histoire
littérature et culture lors de ces
journées du patrimoine dans le parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse des lieux fermés qui ont pu
être découverts ou redécouverts par le
public
on reste dans le domaine de la culture
en ce lundi 23 septembre avec de
nouveaux invités sur ce plateau alexa
d'argent bonsoir vous êtes auteur et
metteur en scène avec vous et clémence
vérone comédienne et emeric et poitevins
comédien et vous êtes de la troupe et
spleen par les moins actifs de cette
troupe donc c'est une compagnie qui est
basée à conflans qui existe depuis 2014
qui a vocation à s'interroger sur la
citoyenneté à travers le théâtre donc là
nous en sommes à notre cinquième
création osiris qui s'appelle donc
osiris on va voir quelques images d'un
teaser que vous avez réalisé justement
une des questions de religion aussi dit
d'exil pardon admiration à raconter non
peu le pitch l'histoire en fait c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune femme athée qui
devient croyante pour donner un sens à
sa vie et donc on assiste à son parcours
donc depuis sa conversion jusqu'à sa
radicalisation à la fin du spectacle
j'ai demandé au comédien justement
comment on se met dans la peau de ses
personnages là et dans des thèmes on va
détailler un petit peu plus ces thèmes
qui sont finalement assez compliqué
aussi abordé est ce que c'est une
difficulté déjà en tant que comédienne
et comédien c'est une difficulté quand
on gagne absolument pas dans le domaine
après moi j'aborde beaucoup dans mes
spectacles parce que j'ai déjà monté un
spectacle aussi la mixité sociale et
notamment je vais beaucoup à la
rencontre des gens pour ma part en tout
cas et est donc c'est à travers la
découverte des gens qu'on apprend à
devenir comme les à savoir ce que ça
fait donc un comédien pour vous ces
thèmes ce qu'ils vous ont fait peur au
tout début
alors c'est pas vraiment peur le terme
parce que en l'occurrence c'est un thème
qui me plaisait énormément c'est surtout
pour ça que j'ai décidé de continuer du
coup avec alex sait la difficulté avait
surtout situés justement dans comment
rendre accessible ce spectacle parce que
sinon sur la manière de travailler on
est un peu enfin quand on a une manière
de travailler en tant que comédien on
les applique de manière assez similaire
quand on a une sorte pas vraiment une
méthode mais plus ou moins
peu importe disons le texte quoi en tout
cas pour le rendre accessible c'est une
autre difficulté
la pièce s'appelle osiris les premières
représentations 11 12 et 13 octobre au
théâtre blanche de castille sur poissy
il ya d'autres présentations carrières
sous poissy aussi et puis à paris
également et le site internet qui s'est
affichée il ya d'autres changements dans
les dalles derrière cette fois ci en
fait c'est là où nous avons répété oui
qu'on n'a pas de représentation prévue
là bas pour l'instant et sur paris on
espère en 2020 mais pour l'instant rien
chercher encore voilà est-ce que c'est
le thème qui a fait peur alors peut-être
justement le religieux qui devient
politique
comment vous avez décidé d'aborder ce
thème là et comment vous avez travaillé
pour aborder ce thème à travers l'angle
de la mythologie tout d'abord puisque du
coup le dieu que ceux choisis
dalila donc le personnage qui se
radicalise c'est dû aux iris un dieu de
la mythologie égyptienne est donc en
fait je pense que ce décalage permet
justement de d'aborder plus facilement
l'angle de la radicalisation son nom
mais dans quelque chose de de trop de
trop calqué sur la réalité
le théâtre pour vous doit être citoyen
engagé et humaniste il doit faire
réfléchir c'est pas uniquement au
divertissement
non ça peut être et l'un et l'autre je
pense je pense qu'on a tous gagnés quand
on sort d'une représentation en se
disant qu'on a passé un bon moment et qu
en plus
voilà ça va nous faire réfléchir sur
certains thèmes je vous vois akessé vous
êtes d'accord
justement il faut il faut apporter autre
chose aussi aux spectateurs le faire
réfléchir
moi je suis plus oui c'est parti là du
du théâtre pour faire réfléchir que le
théâtre du divertissement
y a pas de censure aujourd'hui dans
l'art justement on voit que tous les
thèmes sont compliqués à aborder
déclenche souvent des polémiques
justement moi je pense que le le
spectacle d'osiris ça a été difficile à
et sera difficile à vendre pour son
thème justement et c'est ça qui est beau
oui parce que même à l'intérieur de la
troupe
il peut y avoir parfois justement des
moments où on se dit ah on aime on écrit
ça est ce qu'on est tous d'accord enfin
c'est pas justement par essence est un
sujet qui peut amener à polémique ou
autre et donc forcément il ya des
sensibilités qui sont différentes et ça
amène justement des questionnements même
à l'intérieur de la troupe et c'est
normal c'est sain d'avoir ces
questionnements là sinon ça serait
étonnant si ce n'était pas le cas donc
on espère en tout cas qu'il y aura
justement que ça fasse écho et qu'il y
ait discussion l'objectif c'est vraiment
qu'il y ait discussion c'est pas juste
on fait une pièce et puis et puis c'est
tout ce serait une solution qui sont
proposées aussi au public à en amont
d'un accompagnement on va dire en
quelque sorte
après la représentation il y aura des
bords de plateau qui sont composées avec
les spectateurs
et puis on essaye aussi d'animer des
ateliers en fonction des possibilités
soit en amont des représentations sont
en aval dont cela se sera pas forcément
le cas à poissy il est des choses qui
vont peut-être se mettre en place par la
suite en partenariat avec des lycées ou
des structures d'accompagnement de
personnes immigrées pourquoi pas faim
voilà cd des pistes qui sont interrogés
sur ce qu'ils étaient juste avant sur
votre écriture aussi est-ce que ça a
joué le fait qu'il puisse y avoir des
discussions au sein de la troupe à ce
que vous avez modifier des choses est ce
que les comédiens ont apporté des choses
aussi vous aviez votre vision déjà ce
spectacle pas tant que ça devait être le
cas sur des spectacles précédents mais
là le texte a vraiment été créée au
départ et au contraire je tenais à ce
qu'ils soient le plus
le plus fidèle possible à l'écriture
originale donc osiris premières
représentations 11 12 et 13 octobre
théâtre non gelée castille à poissy une
fois de plus je renvoie vers le site
internet si vous voulez en savoir plus
et puis aussi vous joindre accueillir si
vous êtes des élus et dans vos communes
les différentes représentations voir des
écoles aussi est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
activités que vous développez aussi vous
disais c'est la cinquième pièce est
trompé de compagnie est tout jeune pour
conclure quelques mots sur la compagnie
le travail que vous menez oui on
travaille aussi beaucoup avec les
bibliothèques on développe beaucoup de
lecture l'a dernièrement on a on a fait
les journées du patrimoine aussi où on a
pu voir une visite théâtralisée
donc disons qu'on a un travail qui ce
qui se développe de plus en plus au delà
des formes de spectacles donc la lecture
c'est aussi quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que ça permet
de travailler sur un thème de manière
beaucoup plus condensée et
donc voilà c'est des choses qu'on va
encore développer par la suite et les
ateliers je pense que c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va arriver se
développer dans les prochains mois des
collèges ou des lycées défavorisés
serait intéressant merci à tous les
trois d'être venu nous présenter aux
iris votre nouvelle création spleen
théâtrale à vous en savez un petit peu
plus sur cette pièce et ses troupes
merci merci
dans un instant le journal des sports
avec les gorilles canal est pour
l'instant juste un dernier chiffre 1150
1150 c'est le nombre de bénévoles des
restos du coeur dans les yvelines
pourquoi ne pas les rejoindre
l'association lança un appel en ce début
d'automne certaines zones autour de
guyancourt de rambouillet de houdan ne
sont pas encore desservies les restos là
qui en appelle aussi à la générosité de
toutes et tous l'an dernier 1,8 million
de repas ont été distribués dans le
département lors de la campagne d'hiver
nouveau pont sur l'information locale
demain 18h en direct
ripley a consultés sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
bonne soirée
[Musique]